all the pieces of marriage is like the
core elements of it you take religion
out of that yeah marriage is nothing but
a statement half of they're predicting
half of women in our age group aren't
even going to be married they're you
know 50 of us in the room never married
no kids that's what they're predicting
women only confuse the intimacy if there
is a problem
I say that because women use it
sometimes as a weapon we do what I'm
talking about because I was responding
to the other one I just said okay look
if you don't clean you don't cook and
you don't have sex with him what does he
get out of that
you're
[Laughter]
okay if you could start if you get fat
oh God you're not loyal because you know
70 to 80 percent of women in the US are
overweight 70 80 yeah so yeah so so
that's one two we're not loyal we leave
70 to 80 percent of the time
on top of that
um one out of four marriages is sexless
so and I I can't imagine most women
really have their original recipes
really cater to men support them so it's
like I can't really say we're doing a
good job as a girl I'm including myself
in this right but I'm just saying as a
group can we say we're we're offering a
lot
I feel like a lot of it comes down to
the fact that marriage is now
a nearly a political statement it's
nothing to do with the religion aspect
of it I'm not religious myself but I
come from a very religious background
I'm I'm born and raised in Northern
Ireland very religious and all the basis
of marriage is like the core elements of
it you take religion out of that yeah
marriage kind of is nothing but a
statement yeah she's right she's no
you're right because it's the because
religion has become you know watered
down and fewer people are religion
religious today and also societal
constraints but the societal constraints
came out of religion didn't they you
know the whole reason that it was so
um frowned upon for people to be
divorced and certainly for women to be
divorced in the past was because of the
religious aspects to it we'll take out
the religion and suddenly it's like well
what is the incentive do you know what I
mean there is no incentive and that's
that's the problem with the marriage
contract now
I also I think that's quite sad because
I feel like marriage has lost its
meaning like let's not forget marriage
is a beautiful thing it's a sacred thing
yeah but that's only that's only if
you're religious that's the issue that
that's coming up I think they come I
don't know
the marriage
I answer I'm saying like in
don't actually get that security the
type of security that you get when
you're married doesn't get sick because
the man doesn't get the security because
70 of the women leave I would say yeah
we don't get security okay we wanted to
work we said send us to work and then we
go to work and now the wages are cut in
half for everyone when you got double
the amount of employees it's her own
fault and then women women who's in
charge of sex right so women set up you
know what I used to require marriage to
have sex with me now we don't do that so
as far as our own fault
broke down because of women
[Music]
I'll tell you I'll tell you this my
grandma my grandma
old lady sweet lady she had nine kids my
dad had 13. my mom had I got a lot big
family right and you know she's getting
older right and I asked her um like
Grandma why do you think like the
divorce rate spiked so much because the
divorce rate really went um up in the
60s right and I was like Grandma like
what like why is that like what what
happened you were you around right
she looks at me she says birth control
made him do it
oh okay
stats the birth control rate and the
divorce rate they're the same
so what are you saying that the birth
control does something to the women kind
of thing now I think women just wanted
to sleep around oh yeah lovely
um
to have a difference in your
yeah because I've had attractiveness
basically it's just what you're
attracted to at the time when you're a
hormonal yeah I heard that I've heard
stories there's some really interesting
research I'm very scientific I I study
science as a degree some really
interesting research on it but it still
doesn't give to a reason have you heard
about women who get married to a dude
when they're on birth control and they
come off
that's not a materialistic thing though
at least at least it's just it's
something a bit deeper there isn't it do
you know why that is is that because
when she's on the birth control she's
looking for a certain type of dude it's
a completely different hormonal
imbalance in the body so when you come
off the birth control is it is different
hormones is it basically when she's on
birth control she's looking for a more
of a dad kind of character then she
comes off it she's looking for life I
think it's a personal preference
you were right because I thought it was
because this isn't when you're on birth
control like the body tricks you into
and you're looking for those aspects
like a strong man man with good
selective genes good and what you want I
thought you wanted the resources because
you already got you but that that's the
you when you feel that you're pregnant
you want that security but then when you
come off it it's just go wild in
it I mean that's the actually though in
it they come off it and they're like
yeah
they want they're more they're more up
for yeah yeah any anything because
there's an idea there's I don't know if
you guys agree with this or not but
there's an idea in the men's online you
know advice space that basically women
look for two different things they look
for the dads and they look for the cats
so they look for the guys who are more
like the provider guys more he's a nice
guy he's Dependable he's solid he's got
a good pension pension planning place
and all that stuff yeah and then you've
got the sexy the sexy dude over here who
maybe hasn't got any of that stuff but
he's ripped to these like Devil May care
and he's like does you know he's that
kind of and and there's this idea that
women look for those two things the way
it sounds like you're saying is that on
the birth control they go for the first
and then they come to birth control
they're like right where's Chad yeah
where's the pool boy anything these days
men wants kids more than woman wants
kids I think it's I um
I think today's society though is not
more about what the man or woman wants
it's more about what's being pushed on
you yeah so a lot of people are thinking
I don't want too many children because
the financial aspect of it or I don't
want too many children because the
environmental aspects of it or it's just
personal preference
yeah exactly and there's a huge amount
of evidence now saying if you're into
your 40s and you're having a child you
increase the risk of them having severe
other problems abnormalities having Down
syndrome and as much as those children
they thrive in life but it's not fair to
push that on them knowing you're you're
going into your 40s and you're having a
child I mean I I don't I don't agree
with it it's not fair when she was 45
not it's not everyone it's not everyone
but the science the science supports it
saying once you reach a certain point
you increase that risk of something like
that happening or still births or having
a child that has fear fatal fatal and
which then into their very very young
years end up dying so I think that's a
lot of the things that now because we
have the research back and up people are
going well it's too late and I don't
wanna I don't want to force that on a
child which is fair which is fair with
both sides man and woman I think it's
both works both ways what age is it over
for a woman
what age is it like it's you're not
gonna be a wife well it's really but it
depends about kids let's talk about okay
let me I'm just going to clarify a
little bit we're not going to talk about
the exceptions I know somebody yeah
there's always going to be acceptable
all right there's always going to be so
I heard a lady gave birth at 60. oh yeah
but nothing knowing knowing that men
today are more hesitant to get married
right and half of they're predicting
half of women in our age group aren't
even going to be married they're you
know 50 of us in the room never married
no kids that's what they're predicting
okay at what age
is it would you say over you know
probably No One's Gonna Marry You no
one's if no one's trying if no one's
tribed in there if no one's tried to
marry you yet you're probably never
gonna get it oh what age what do you
think
um as a woman
um what age would you say when you're a
spinster like no offense like for late
late 40s 45 late over okay kind of yeah
when do you think it's over oh yeah I'd
say probably 45 and over yes okay 45
same yeah 40. I'm gonna come back to you
45.
I think because a lot of people because
people who are getting married tend to
want families doesn't it so they're
going to look at them and go what if I
might love you but I yeah but in
traditional aspects marriages to support
a family and they might look at it and
go we're most likely not going to have a
child so I mean if I'm not religious is
there any point get married at this
point that's why I said I didn't say
relationship no marriage all right Trey
what do you think what age uh 27. 27. oh
my God
I knew that would trigger though I knew
that would trigger everyone out I just
like the precises
in all seriously so if we're talking
about having kids though as well like
not just are we talking marriage and
kids this is just personally I feel like
most guys over a certain age they'll get
in a long-term relationship with a girl
but why get married if there's no kids
yeah no true true so true at what age is
it would you say as a guy you're like um
couldn't start a family with her you can
have that to me but if you don't have
kids so if she if you had a girl you
really liked right and you were thinking
of someone you wanted to start a family
with but you said you know what too old
I mean to be honest I think it's going
to be like mid-30s yeah yeah
realistically because of the things
you're talking about as well because you
start to think getting much older than
that you start thinking well you know
would everything be be okay you know
um
yeah
because if you think about it what a
women's Peak fertility use really yeah
it's like 22 23 right yeah yeah yeah
just under 25 I think yeah you start
reaching 30 that's when it starts we're
getting quite dangerous yeah 90 of your
eggs are gone by 30. yeah wow crazy
that's why marriage used to be so much
younger that's why people used to get
married a lot younger but now now a lot
of people don't want to have children so
they get married a lot later because
it's yeah I mean you could definitely if
it's just if it's just marriage for like
companionship then to be fair people
could get married older you know like
you might meet somebody you know in the
nursing home and you're just like all
right
on the death bed oh my God I need to
spend this money
I noticed are you engaged I saw the I
see that me no I always get asked this
no this is um on the right hand not on
the left hand oh okay no everyone always
asks me that no not yet soon maybe
hopefully how funny we pray
um okay next question next question
because I feel like I was given so much
Flack for this
are you a good wife if you get married
and then you gain 100 pounds is that
good wife
I'm just I'm just asking am I off base I
mean was there a reason for that like
it's so impossible it doesn't matter the
reason I mean you're not a bad wife for
gaining a hundred pounds
so like okay let me let me just say so I
lost my job and refused to work as a
husband but I did it for a reason
am I a good husband
you know I lost my job but I was
depressed I mean I think that happened
it could be on benefits yeah I didn't
say I didn't say that it doesn't happen
I didn't say you couldn't work through
it I just said good good means like a
student good A B student right that's
good um I don't know I kind of need
specifics because like gaining weight
and being depressed
obviously you can gain weight as a girl
because you're depressed okay
so so you know I got married I'm in love
I'm just gonna just getting Krispy
creams every day if if you're not
willing to look out for your own health
though yeah yeah
no I don't I don't think it is so my
question good wife or bad wife
see I don't think it's I don't think
it's quite as straightforward but in it
I have a question you have to pick one
you gotta pick good or bad I have a
question I I would say if I'm still
looking after him and doing all the
things that a wife should do but yeah I
just gained a few pounds or whatever I
said 100. yeah what still looking after
him he can't say nothing I'm still a
good wife
all right I'm gonna get the same person
like does it change does it look at
Piers Brosnan is that his name is that
his wife the old James Bond his wife was
stunning when they were young and now if
you look at her she's gained a lot of
weight and he told them he was like I
didn't fall in love with her because of
the way she looked he was like I fell in
love with her soul yeah yeah I think
that sounds like I don't know why men
cap he would not have approached her
come on like
they sell us this fairy tale you know
I'm not saying that she can't provide
other things but that action all right
can we just sorry that action is that a
good wife I didn't talk about her
cooking
as well like if you don't care and
there's no backline issue to why you've
done that no it's a bad way yeah it's a
because if you don't care and you've
gone you should love me the way I am if
that's how it was in the beginning then
that's why maybe I'm coming across a bit
strong did you say she was oh she was
real who said they're real she's the
realest so far
okay okay next one on my list all right
if you refuse to have sex with your
husband good wife or bad wife bad okay
thank you thank you good night for bad
refused yeah
I need contacts yeah like I have no idea
what that means I think in a
stereotypical sense because normally
when a woman refuses is because there's
an emotional disconnect or there's
something that's seriously going wrong
then should you still be married then or
should you got married and satisfied no
but I mean
I have a question do good wives put
their feelings above what's best for the
family
yeah oh it's me well I don't I don't
feel right so let me just not sleep with
my husband because of the way I feel is
that a good wife my feelings before
everybody else's I mean as long as
you've expressed that to your partner
and he's okay with that no I don't have
to be open I just wanna I just don't
have a question I'm just just yes
do you think most men would be okay with
having a wife that does not have sex
with them no no okay no I think it'd be
a problem okay yeah it won't be
problematic okay so because you guys
were like well maybe if I explain to him
why I'm not is there a reason they could
give you you're like you
just not have sex I think that
honest I think that might make it worse
if she's trying to justify it it's like
because the problem is what the guy's
giving you is his commitment he's giving
you his commitment I'm not going to
sleep with anyone else and then he's and
then if you're also not having sex with
him then obviously that's going to leave
him in a deficit yeah but there's
obviously a reason for it but it depends
yeah it really has to depend what that
reads for example if she's with like an
abusive man that's a completely that's
one of those extremities
why do we keep going to the extreme when
we're talking about the norm
the intimacy if there is a problem
I say that because women use it
sometimes as a weapon we do yeah yeah
and I don't think that's okay yeah
that's not okay but she's probably using
it as a weapon because there is a valid
reason but could she be not wanting to
be intimate with him because just
because the butterflies are gone just
because she's like no see that's wrong
like something really like Oh you mean
it's wrong she does that but why do you
guys okay yeah why do we keep adding
things to avoid the
question is not sleep
that is the question it's not if you're
an abusive
are you a good wife if you won't have
sex with your husband without the
extremities I think is what she's trying
to say okay that's so confusing to me
because I'm trying to put my mind so I
have a friend he's a 20-year divorce
attorney he says it's very common that
women get the two kids they want and
they just stop sleeping with the husband
they got what they want okay no that's
wrong
and a lot of times it's not for a really
good reason woman we have Stu like it
depends where we are in our cycle we're
crazy
I'm mad at your boyfriend for something
stupid yes all the time and like every
day you don't think good wives know that
you know we can be crazy we can be
emotional so we put the family before us
feelings
yeah yeah yeah anyone disagree with that
no okay
okay so good wives have sex even when
they don't want to yes or no I think
that's a connection
yeah yeah sure yes
yes she doesn't she's fighting it
it's hard because I don't agree with it
so yeah I'll say yeah yeah whatever you
guys the same
yeah but but I I it depends on what kind
of of time of frame like time frame that
you're talking about if you just mean in
general yeah
there should even if you're not feeling
totally up to it but you haven't had it
in a while it's a respect thing yeah
you're married to them give like I would
want the same from them so yeah back and
forth in it but if there was some in it
underlying
Irish when I leave at a London
but yeah yeah I think if if it's a just
you know it's a back and forth in it
like you have to
another question okay how many meals if
we're talking an a student the best
wives how many meals should a good wife
cook for her husband a day
a good a student
no how many
one no that's an A okay what about you
one one that's an a student okay I'm
gonna say two that's okay that's an A A
okay how many mules yeah how many meals
there's three minutes lunch and dinner
yeah how many meals and snacks
breakfast
sometimes
um
uh I'm gonna say one and a half like
you do the prep who does the cook yeah
all right what about you
um I quite like cooking so I do three
three Good Wife okay don't what would
you say that a good husband pays a
hundred percent of the bills a plus
husband
no no a plus like like this is the the
ideal like again we're always I'm
talking I do ideal
I don't think you should pay for
everything okay I think his money is our
money my money is my money
oh no I'm sorry
okay do good wives look at their money
as the family money or is their own
money
the a plus wives family family yeah
where is this where does this meant like
you don't think that's a selfish
mentality it is yeah it is
oh my God yeah so like
um if my husband has money and I have
money like it's for the family okay
basically if I've answered and you you
high-fived her why why
um
because I kind of agree with that like
yeah like my money is my money
he knows that I can do what I want with
that obviously because I'm a good wife I
am going to invest that in it yeah I'm
gonna I'm not gonna spend it I'm
probably gonna invest it in my kids I'll
maybe have like 20 for me to go get my
hairs done
look good for my man yeah of course
in return he gets one meal a day
he gets one meal a day all right he gets
two he gets lunch and dinner but
breakfast is off the cards I wake up
late
[Music]
would you spoil your mum yeah because
you said that your money's your own so
would you just spend on yourself or
would you no I'm gonna spoil my mind
what do you mean like especially
no you see something that he really
likes you're like you know what I'm
gonna get this woman yeah yeah with mine
are you gonna are you gonna buy him
let's say what's an expensive watch
listen no honestly if I'm making that
type of money I will buy him his
favorite one yeah okay now another
question do good wives give up their
careers for their children
I think yes yes
oh yeah who's yes yes she doesn't like
it definitely is no I don't I'm talking
a plot remember this is I'm not saying
everyone's got to be an a student and
everything no no I don't give up your
careers no oh good good wives should go
to work instead of spend time with their
kids no for a certain amount of time
yeah you know I get it you know saying
hey with your kid but definitely going
back I believe I mean so I'm talking
about when push comes to shut your kids
need you yeah so if you're gonna have
children they should always come first
regardless whether a man or a woman I
mean yeah yeah okay this is this is the
problem with Society at the minute this
is the problem with Society now no but
it is that they have children and they
focus on Career if you want to have a
child and you're gonna have to sacrifice
whether you're a man or a woman you have
to sacrifice because you work on so many
children so many children are
emotionally neglected because they're
passed off to to nannies or their pass
off to yeah I'm if you're willing to
have a child you need to have a
financial support to be able to go I'm
going to take a step back I'm not going
to quit work you don't have to quit it
just take a step back to be able to go
this child needs me emotionally for the
next 17 years of its life you know what
I mean Rich
the gestation period of humans is much
longer good good wives are happy to give
up their careers to spend more time with
their children yes okay yeah okay yes
you agree yes yeah okay why aren't you
like I'm just curious like why why
wouldn't you want to give up your career
for a kid I mean of course I would like
in the beginning they're growing up I
have to be there
um but I don't believe in like
completely cutting off your career just
because of your kid of course you love
your child that is you get that's you
you gave birth to that child I
understand that but completely
neglecting your career something that
you've like worked for maybe you've gone
to University
um you know you've you're driven in this
you love it and you've given it up I
just don't believe in that wow
and you wanted this family right yeah
most of the time you can come back to it
though yeah but not for 17 years I'm not
going to take a break
I never say it I never say just drop the
careers you shouldn't you don't think
good wives would want to like good wives
if they could take 17 18 years off to
raise the kids what's so good about I
mean a lot of jobs are pretty good
anyway to be honest I mean what's so
good about like we're the only species
on the planet that work and pay to live
on the earth if you're going to raise
something that's so natural you should
be willing to drop some of that
materialistic aspect if you have the
support surrounding it but I think it
works both for a man and a woman I don't
think you should if if you're a single
dad you should and you have the
financial support there you should
definitely want to spend more time with
your child and maybe put your career as
a second second best yeah I mean surely
what is the ultimate purpose that we run
this planet it's it's other people isn't
it it's children it's fast it's family
it's all of those things right I mean
why is any of us men or women why are we
saying oh just going and work in a
cubicle is more important than that
um you know I have another statement
okay
good wives don't leave no matter what
I didn't do something outside let me let
me I'll give you please don't say abuse
please I will give you this I will give
you abuse but good you know what
good wives believe in separations they
don't believe in divorce
um
what do you say separation do you mean
do you mean legally separated basically
living in the same place
I had that growing up I grown up with my
parents and I and I that's normal to me
actually no I have to say that's more
painful
they got divorced for me it was as a
child it was so much
you don't legally yeah but I I'm saying
I think but you live separate in two
different houses so that's basically the
same no sometimes you live in the house
yeah that's how we were we lived in the
house that's what happened to me
so tell me your thoughts do good wives
leave yes or no and good wives only
believe in separation they don't believe
in divorce
what do you think tell me why here
um I mean if you want to leave leave
honestly it doesn't make you a bad
person I just just leave like if
I don't know this or you're just not
feeling anymore like both of you it's a
mutual thing or okay just leave I don't
believe in that separation so a good
wife can leave
okay go ahead
uh yeah I do agree with you
um only because based of my personal
experience and watching my parents be
like that I always grew up wanting them
to actually get a divorce because it was
so damaging to us as children
so I feel like
life is way too short to stay in a
marriage with someone that you are not
happy with and to continue living a
miserable life yeah why why put yourself
through that why put your kids through
that as well if kids are involved as
well so I do think you can still be a
good wife but you can also leave let me
do it for the kids yeah like well
because kids have better outfits yes I'm
saying stay together for the kids no I
don't like no I've seen more no no yeah
but see I as I was the kid and I always
wanted my parents to get a divorce I
would even tell them why don't you guys
get a divorce because it was so painful
seeing them be the way they were with
each other living that separated life in
the same house but how do you how do you
know it would have been a better outcome
for you you seem to have turned out okay
right thank you so figure out what
appearance doesn't necessarily indicate
what's going on in the inside though
yeah exactly but I'm saying I've been
here like I don't know
um
every statistic statistic will tell you
it's better to have two parents in the
same house than it is
I know but then that kid also has to
deal with that trauma for example I have
trauma now growing up you may see me
like this but like you don't know how I
am inside like I have childhood trauma
now because of my parents marriage and
witnessing what went on in that house
because they did not uh get a divorce
did they not get along they would fight
a lot yeah absolutely they did not get
along and really and truly they should
have got divorced but because of the
kids they stayed and because my mom
believed in this whole I need to be a
good wife and I can't leave him now that
he's old and throw him out she stayed
but I wish she would have got divorced
because that was really painful as a
child growing up to see those things
what if one of them have moved out
though and you hadn't seen them as much
would that have been painful as well do
you think I think either way you would
that either way it would have been but I
actually would have preferred that if
they had got different house yeah I
would have liked my dad my dad's not
alive anymore
um but I would have liked it if he moved
out and we saw him on weekends or
something because I feel like it would
have been a healthier environment for us
kids I think it causes a divide and a
toxic household as well yeah it was an
extremely toxic household it was and it
was really hard growing up dealing with
that actually
um and it's also given me trauma now
that you know I'm in a relationship and
I'm planning to get married and I worry
that I'm gonna have the same life my mum
and dad had which is a horrible feeling
but that is what kids who go through
those things end up feeling when they
get to my age do you think that's me do
you look at
kind of marriage as a more kind of
solid thing now though you look at it
and you go I have to want this so badly
yeah before I get it's like I want to
break the generational curse now because
because it's a lot of women in my family
unfortunately left their husbands
um that's that at least that's a
positive outlook that you've got on it
you can look at it and be like yeah I
want to be a relationship that's yeah
that's strong and can hold together even
through hardship you can be like yeah I
don't want what happened before yeah
they said something you can kind of yeah
have you ever seen a healthy
relationship no I don't have a
representation of a healthy relationship
no so how how would you learn how to be
a wife
um I'm doing a lot of inner work like
I'm really searching inwards I
you know I've looked into therapy I I've
tried to work on myself I tried to work
on my traumas I really want to break
that generational curse
um so I have healthy open com you know
conversations with my mum about these
things in the past and her marriage with
my Dad we talk about these things on a
daily basis
um so I feel like I I have
I have the right mindset now because I
know what I don't want and I don't want
that unhealthy toxic environment that
unfortunately I grew up in as a child I
don't want my kids to go through that so
I feel like all the things that my mum
and dad went through I don't want to be
reenacting those in my marriage
um when it goes back to what you just
asked
um I agree with you
um I don't have any parents in my life
mom or dad
um I had a mom who played a woman and a
father
um but I think when it comes to
relationships and what you choose I
think it comes to choices and what you
learn I think the world I think that's
quite big to be honest but I think just
like learning from people around you you
just kind of sit back and be like do I
like that do I accept that
um and I think it's just Choice really
what makes you happy and you just build
yourself if that makes sense like with
me I think Love's beautiful I would like
I love that yeah I would love to get
married and it's not just marriage you
know I understand where you're coming
from it's like signing a paper and I get
where you where like you come from I
understand that but I feel like
there's someone out there for everyone I
agree you know yeah and I yeah I agree
with you and I think I would love to get
that opportunity maybe another country
why did you think that that why because
what was that I didn't even hear it
there's not there's not someone for
everyone
why yeah because some women die alone a
lot of women do they do all the time
some men die alone but how'd you know
they didn't have the love of their life
yeah oh and they lost it yeah because
one out of three men are because
[Laughter]
there's more women than men on the
planet so if every woman had someone
there would be eat 50 50. but there's
also yeah
there are people like me there's there's
a good question do you see yourself
sorry a bit topic but I'm just quite
curious would you do you see yourself
marrying a man or not like again I would
only ever get married if that other
person really wanted it but I I've
actually this is probably the first time
I've ever openly come out that's very
sexual
like publicly and but yeah I mean I yeah
either way if if it meant a lot to the
other person and I
you know felt like it I was in a
possession in my life to be like that's
really does that means so much to you I
want to be able to give that to you
would you marry a woman yeah yeah
but
I I again it wouldn't be because I want
even with the nagging
who here thinks I just want to raise a
hand who thinks good wives don't leave
you do everyone else thinks good wives
leave oh actually wait no good wives
will never leave good good wives you you
think that I don't think you're no
you're not a wife if you leave I think
if you sign up for something
what do you mean you're not you're no
longer a wife if you leave are you
you're no longer so so you're neither or
someone else's wife yeah but you're no
in that situation you're no longer the
wife to be a good wife
I'm just gonna I just kind of want to
break this down okay this is why men are
complaining it's like they maybe get one
meal from a good wife and she's she's
okay to leave if she feels like it and
we fight I mean he's okay to leave as
well like it's a two-way station
but the thing is we don't have anything
on the line if a man marries you you I'm
doing a documentary on the court system
here you you literally are paid like
lawyers um
you are you get a free counsel here if
you say that he abused you and you can
deny him access for his kids up to two
years trying to get like he doesn't have
a chance in court vice versa no it's not
Vice no no but vice versa it's so much
harsher on the man no it's so it's so
much harsher on the man to the point
ninety percent of the time
um women get custody yeah and it's
actually like it's actually a really
it's really sad I'm interviewing some of
the guys that have like been through it
it's there are guys that haven't seen
their kid in four years because they're
exacus them of abuse and they never did
it and there's no proof there's no
problem because there's no proof that
doesn't mean anything that doesn't it
doesn't mean that they do something okay
you think it's do you think it's okay to
deny access to children with no evidence
of a crime
no evidence they never press charges no
evidence I think it very much we should
just take take women's word amber
heard's word
that's another that's another thing
so it's like what are guys getting out
of this um
is it just um is it just what do you say
abuse is it also like mental coercion as
well and they're expanding that's what
they're doing they're expanding the
definition of abuse of if a girl says oh
I want to buy two thousand dollars worth
of addresses and he says it now that he
can put that under like mental Financial
coercion or something or if he said if
he said oh stop following guys on
Instagram or something like that could
be seen as manipulation yeah it's really
scary the more there's this one story
where the woman
um accused him of of touching the kids
and remember and remember remember
they're financially incentivized to do
that and then what they can do is they
go to Family Court and in family court
you don't actually have a jury to judge
you of your peers which you should be
entitled to and so they can go to Family
Court and deny you access to your kids
until they actually
um
finish yeah and that can take up to two
years so if he has a newborn he won't
see the kid for two years and she has no
punishment if she lied like this is what
Manner this is what men have to deal
with here and it's like well if she lied
honestly I feel like she should have
punishment that that should be but you
know what happened to him he killed
himself oh well but they but they women
do get punished for for example like I
don't really know but it's like she
accuses the man of like not in family
sexually assaulting no they don't and
family I'm telling you I've interviewed
the guys that they don't it's really sad
and so it's like the guys are like well
what do we get out of this and we can't
even like admit we can't even say what's
a good wife what's a bad wife
because everyone has their own
experiences their own interpretations
yeah but we know vaguely what's a good
husband what's a bad husband a husband
you wouldn't want a husband that like
doesn't protect you that if someone
tries to beat you up he's like oh go do
it yourself babe
we could say in generalities that women
like men want thin wives in general I
mean maybe slim thicker they're allowed
to say that they want to say that they
can say that right but I'm saying we
can't even say it they can't even get
three meals out of us for a good
remember I kept saying an A plus student
except except you
she she gives three meals
I like cooking so it's like there we go
you've got to like doing something
haven't you to be